Piggy dit
[Musique]
Je ne suis pas
maintenant
tu es ce que je t'ai fait
J'ai été enlevé par la RDA
et formé à leurs manières
pendant 15 ans, ils m'ont gardé de mon monde
et mon peuple
attend
tu as la marque
tu es Sorrente
la pauvre enfant  ne sait rien de nos voies, cet
arbre de la maison soit un refuge contre tes
fardeaux.
Je dois chercher ceux qui peuvent m'apprendre les
voies du non-être et m'aider à me reconnecter
avec mon monde.
Suis-moi.
Je ne te ferai pas de mal non.
[Musique]
tu commences.  penser comme si de rien n'était
maintenant, nous allons vous apprendre à rouler comme un seul
[Musique]
Pandora est à nouveau attaquée
Je ne permettrai pas à la RDA de détruire cette
terre,
c'est ma maison
[Musique]
et pas moi et je protégerai Pandora